[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in carson palmer how many
times you play on thanksgiving
uh a big fat zero for me okay
that sounds like a good thing
no the the thursday night games are
great when they're appropriately
scheduled when you have that friday
saturday sunday off to recover and rest
and sit around and watch football that's
the best as long as you're not beat up
and and sore going into that thursday
game from the previous sunday but
players love the thursday games if
they're appropriately timed and they
didn't play previously on monday night
or something like that but getting that
long weekend is fantastic for the
players it's really tough though to you
know you play sunday and you got to turn
around and play thursday on on just a
normal week and now you have this i
can't imagine that you can be prepared
physically and mentally for a game with
three days in between
well it's it's neat at the same time
both teams are
with a limited schedule for for mental
prep but the the issue or the veteran
teams when when you have a team like
pittsburgh who's stacked with a bunch of
29 to 34 year olds
it's hard on those guys when you're 22
23 you can play on sunday and probably
turn around and play again on tuesday if
you had to but those older guys those
veteran teams those teams that have a
bunch of guys
that are in their maybe late 20s early
30s that have to turn around and play on
thursday that those are the teams it's
really tough on ucla and usc this
weekend uh carson played against ucla
three times i got you passing for
824 yards nine touchdowns one
interception you went 3-0 outscoring
ucla 117 to 56.
uh what'd you make of that game on
saturday
uh it's time for the season to get over
it
we're ready for an off season we're
ready for a coaching change and the new
regime to come in and put their stamp on
the program it's it's time
hey got any new coaching candidates
not today okay good not today i still
got a couple guys earmarked but i don't
know if you and i are allowed to talk
about those guys on air anymore uh
before you were coming on paulie goes
how far do you think carson palmer's
ever thrown a football
so we're going to guess here todd i'll
start with you how how far
73 yards now this isn't in a game this
is life
okay so 73 yards mclovin
i'm gonna prices write him 75 yards can
i see what you're doing there seaton
75 and a half
holy because you said life and not a
football game i'm gonna go 81 yards
i'm gonna go 76 yards
carson your answer uh
the the farthest i've grown is 73 i
think 73.
73.
somebody threw 73 out there i'm not sure
was that yeah that was me all right 73
baby
smart guy first in his class right uh
second
second
second in his class he cheated off oh
stop you did cheat i was second in
junior high school and high school you
could add that while you rip me for like
looking at my friend's paper once in a
while but you but that's called cheating
it's called checking your answers to
make sure you got what you wrote down
right
when you cheated at usc carson how did
you do it
well i didn't really cheat i just didn't
go to class
that's what usc has to get back to
yeah we're getting there like i said we
need the season to get over
we need to forget about 2021 and really
2020 and 2019 but we need to move on
2022 is our year watch out best win of
the weekend was turned in by
which team in the nfl
the best win of the weekend is i need
these bill or i need these uh who's
playing tonight i need them the giants
and the buccaneers oh i need the g-men
for a five-team stream parlay
if they can just cover 11
100 bet wins me 2 000 bucks
and they're my fifth leg so that's my
biggest win i don't even need the g men
to win i just need them to cover okay
but
because all i really we're not uh we're
worried about me here right man so i
need the job are you down on your luck i
mean are you
do you need the money is everything okay
at the palmer household
uh everything's okay but there's no
better money than money one okay
so that five teamer streamer i'm a big
five-teamer streamer i love throwing
them out there they never come through
or hardly ever do so i need my gm in
tonight just just keep it within 10.
that's all i'm asking okay but the worst
win the the worst game of the week
the worst loss um was that bill's indie
game i mean i i was high on the bills i
was loving watching them play and they
just showed up
and they showed that they have an issue
with with a physical running football
team and i didn't think that would be an
issue but they didn't want to tackle
jonathan taylor i mean there were arm
tackles broken there were guys coming to
the point of attack and kind of turning
it down
um
and that's not what you expected from a
sean mcdermott buffalo bills defense and
i know that defense is built for speed
and they're built to play with a lead
but if you can run the ball and jump out
against the buffalo bills
i'm a little bit worried about them and
i'm a little bit worried about and i
love josh i love the qb but he's
starting to throw uh he's starting to
make some poor decisions and panic i
mean he threw a pick on third and 18 or
19 years old 19 yards that you just
can't throw in that situation and then
you know he he panicked again on another
third down and had a receiver about
eight yards away from him through an
absolute pistol at him and it went right
through his hands and bounced into the
hands of the defending team and you know
there's some issues in buffalo i think
that was glaring i think that was easily
the worst the worst loss of the week and
i'm a little concerned about them moving
forward i just want to follow up a piss
missile
is that what you said yeah i mean it was
yeah it was about a 10-yard pass and he
threw a 95 on our fastball and you just
you got to take care of your guys on
those shorter underneath routes and you
know as a fan you can sit there and go
well it hit his receiver in the hands
but that ball was only coming you know
15 yards in the air and it was going
like i said 95 miles an hour
you got to have a little touch on and
it's a it's a little bit of a panic
you're seeing in in josh you know you're
down a couple scores you feel like you
got to make something happen you try to
squeeze one in on third and 18 when you
just need to take the check down throw
it out of bounds and punt and and that's
that was my worst loss of the week it's
got me concerned in buffalo once again
it's a piss missile
it's a piss missile okay i've never
never heard of a pistol no
no you can use it yeah you can use it
okay
i don't know how i'll use it i mean it
doesn't come up in conversation around
the dinner table with my wife but
it's radio talk it's tv talking oh yeah
well you know i love the nfl terminology
sometimes that you know i get caught on
uh caught up on i just uh you know i
haven't i haven't heard that one before
you got any other ones that are
like inside football
yeah i've got a bunch but i'm gonna save
it for next monday what
i'll just give you one a week is that
fair
okay
yeah sure
okay all right um do the chiefs have a
decent defense like they have a defense
that is good enough to help them go to
the super bowl again
they've got they've obviously got a good
enough defense to get into the playoffs
but
if you if you again if you can jump up
on them and run the ball they're not
built to stop the run they're built to
have a lead and so
um yeah they played a lot better and
that was kind of the game we've all been
waiting for kansas city to play you know
where patrick looked really confident
with the ball there's still some travis
kelsey issues you saw on the pick that
bounced off his chest but they're
starting to figure some things out on
defense but that team is built for speed
that team is built to play with a 14 21
point lead where you have to throw it on
them if they catch a team like indy that
comes in and runs the ball and gets real
physical with them and owns the time of
possession and doesn't give the ball to
patrick mahomes they are very
susceptible to being beat but i wonder
about that when we get to the playoffs
and we saw this with the titans you know
a couple years ago they were up big on
kansas city couldn't hold on but that
team that's run first
and because everybody it feels like
their defenses are smaller and faster
built for speed whereas you get a team
that has a good offensive line and just
able to run the football
indianapolis could be a tough out
because of that because you don't not
many teams are built that way the titans
are colts are uh philadelphia runs the
football but they're not going to be a
playoff caliber team so that that could
be
that could be an interesting team to run
up against the colts
yeah i mean when you look at what derek
henry was doing the last three or four
years in tennessee he was an anomaly
they were an anomaly everybody else was
built to throw it
and
it's not that you know derek henry is
obviously a great back that offensive
line is really good they're just so
different and they're so difficult to
prepare for and they're so difficult to
practice
during the week because you got a back
that is so different than everybody else
now now bringing it back to indy i mean
indy's kind of similar jonathan taylor
there aren't many backs built like him
right now i mean it was him and and
really derek henry that are 230 pounds
plus that can run away from you there's
a lot of smaller quicker shiftier backs
but they are not an anomaly and that
offensive line in indy is much better
than that offensive line in tennessee so
i mean i i do think they're a problem if
ty hill ty hilton can stay healthy
jonathan taylor stays healthy and carson
wins that defense is a division champ
type defense that defense is a playoff
defense they got play makers in the back
end leonard who who does such a great
job from a leadership standpoint at
linebacker and russian the pastor and
speed and quickness cover the backs out
of the backfield
they're going to be a difficult team
we've seen carson wentz struggle early
on this year it looks like he's starting
to kind of iron out some of those
problems he was having if he can
continue to play the way he played
yesterday they are going to be a tough
out
do quarterbacks like having that running
game
like that means less throws but
are you you know do you think most of
these guys are come to do you think
patrick mahomes is comfortable handing
the ball off
absolutely the the quarterbacks want to
play against a single high single safety
defense and you can do that
when
you know a team that can't throw it
comes up to you and you can play single
high defense but when you get back and
play too high defense and you have that
second safety deep covering the pass
and you can run the ball from a
quarterback's perspective you love it it
helps the play action pass game it helps
get you more single high safety looks
which is an advantageous thing for an
offense to be in because now there's
more holes and more voids in the defense
when you can't run the ball and defenses
can put another safety back there's less
holes in the defense and less voids in
the defense to throw into so a
quarterback like patrick mahomes
russell wilson al all these great
quarterbacks that we're watching play
tom brady running game and handing the
ball off is a great thing when you're
averaging over four yards of pop they
all love that
you ever go to the line of scrimmage and
forget the play
yes
what do you do
uh it only happened a couple times one
time it was on a run play and i just i
knew it was a run i just forgot which
way it was going and i opened up to the
left and the back went to the right and
i think i took a four yard loss five
yard loss and one time i dropped back
actually i completely forgot what the
play was it was third and long
and i don't know what i called and i
still to this day don't know what i
called i just called something in the
huddle and found somebody that actually
got open
got the first down and moved on and
hadn't talked about it since until now
but like how's that happen
were you did you get your bell rung
i'm actually i'm actually surprised it
didn't happen more because i i have a
roo i have a problem with short-term
memory loss and i got hit in the head a
bunch
and i'm surprised it only happened twice
but i do remember those two pla those
two plays in my career and i'm actually
thinking back to the past play and i
probably did have a little bit of a bell
rung and had an issue with that and
that's probably why that happened how
many official concussions did you have
i only had one that that uh put me in
the hospital overnight where i don't
remember the game i don't remember the
previous day i woke up in the hospital
with my buddy frosty rucker who was a
a teammate of mine a couple different
stops and my wife sitting in the
hospital room waiting for me to wake up
and i just kind of came to and had no
clue what was going on where i was so
that was my really only official
official concussion
how many unofficial do you think you had
a good baker's dozen
somewhere around there
were you good at hiding
hiding concussions yeah
you know it really wasn't a topic um
until the last until about 10 years ago
so my first half of my career
there were bell rungs they were you know
you got you got dinged up you got your
you got you got a little uh a little
sleepy on a hit i mean there was terms
for it it wasn't an official concussion
it but it wasn't until 10 years ago
where people were like all right that
was a concussion you need to go into the
protocol
he gave us piss missile this week who
knows what he'll give us next week
we're rooting for the giants tonight
just 10 points we don't need them to win
we just need them to cover for the five
team screen but you're going to be
yelling at brady you're rooting against
tom brady tonight aren't you 100
[Laughter]
for two grand
help out carson palmer please give
happy thanksgiving carson thanks for
joining us
happy thanksgiving that's uh carson
palmer joining us courtesy of the cbd
trusted by professional athletes level
select cbd provides targeted relief
helps treat everyday discomfort when you
need it the most